i also want to quickly ask you about
suicide
squad to the suicide squad
i saw a little bit of it in adr and it
looks incredible it's a fun one it's
different
than the first one i haven't seen you in
so long
i know it's not been too long i want to
start a
new show chop it up it's gonna come out
on facebook watch
and not only are you the host but you
also are a producer on this series
so i first want to know what is it about
this show that sets it apart i guess
from other cooking
type shows i feel like that's such a
great question because i don't look at
chop it up as
a cooking show i look at it as
a conversation series and we're cooking
by way of talking if that makes sense
there's nothing
out there right now where the older
generations can really
understand and and feel how
ginzi is feeling so i
wanted to make chop it up happen where i
just invite some homies over
and i'm cooking their favorite snack but
the focus of the show
is talking about topics that mean the
most to us
whether that's dating or ethical
technology
or family or everything in between it
just gives us an opportunity
to talk and and connect but also gets my
supporters um just a better view into
who we are as people
sure what do you hope that we learn
about you through this series or what
will we be surprised
to learn i feel like everybody knows me
as like yes storm is an
actress and we've seen her in these
projects but i feel like it just
gives you another look at like who i am
and what i have interests in
my episode with niles fitch he talks
about his cousin richard brooks who was
murdered
in 2020 by the police so it's just
different things to wear
it's a it's a full range of topics but
in a macro sense we're talking about
again
things that mean the most to us do you
feel like
with that last episode that you
mentioned um niles finch do you feel
like
we're going to learn more about your
take
um i guess on black lives matter and
police brutality do you hope that we
can take away more from the conversation
through this episode
absolutely i feel like we both are so
passionate about
black lives matter and and the movement
and the
things that we have continued to see but
i feel like they were amplified
uh last year um but we just really
unbridly expressed ourselves and
expressed how we felt
and and really we wanted the audience to
know that
yes there are things that are
heartbreaking and some days we might not
have the words to summon
of of how we're feeling and then other
days we might have
all the words and and we're talking all
day um
but we want people to know that we're
here and we're here to stay and we're
here to take up space
you don't it's only when i'm around you
i just you know
i'm a little could we potentially see
zendaya
on the show i wish maybe next season
maybe next season oh you know that's my
big yes
my big sis i do want to quickly talk
about euphoria season 2 because we
it's just such a good show we saw the
two sort of solo standalone episodes
focused on
rue and then jules where does season two
pick up in relation to those episodes
oh i mean i feel like they're totally
separate
right before we went into lockdown which
was march
13th i'll never forget it we were
actually
doing table reads for season two and the
scripts were incredible but
i hear that they have changed immensely
so i don't really even know
how or what direction season two is
gonna go in
um but if it does stay the same or if
some of the scripts stay the same
it's it's truly incredible and sam
he continues to outdo himself so you
guys aren't even back in production on
season two yet
so we don't start the full production up
until uh i think a couple weeks and
maybe a couple months i just want to get
back
in there that is
honestly that is crazy though because
for some reason i thought you guys were
potentially already
shooting or had some sort of idea where
things were going do you think they
would include the pandemic
um in the show um i don't know
but i i feel like it would be very
relatable i mean that's why i feel like
people
love our show is because we are very raw
uncut and we show what's going on in the
world so
i wouldn't be surprised if sam slipped
that in there
yeah okay that's fair is there anything
that you would love to see
in gia's journey i mean we saw her in
season one
sort of test the waters would there be
trouble ahead
for her possibly i mean
she i feel like even though we didn't
really get to see much
of her in season one i feel like she is
the anchor or the
root to rue and and that's her little
sister
and of course the things that rue does
or the things that rue even says
affects her and her family but i think
we'll be able to see
gia grow up a little bit and become
herself and whether
she makes the right decisions or the
wrong decisions we're just gonna have to
see but
i'm excited to get to explore her and
for people to really
learn who she is as a as a character i
love that um
we we obviously watch the show you have
such a good
head on your shoulders how do you not
slip
into the mistakes that we see so often
a in the world but also in this show
what's this
for you in in staying so on top of
everything
i i would say one above all else is just
my faith
um and believing in in god and
knowing that everything happens for a
reason two
my family and my mama um they keep me
grounded they keep me sane and they
always
bring me back when i need it when i need
to be brought back
um and then i would say
three is just me accepting that i must
just a 17 year old girl
trying to figure it out even though i
get to do all these cool things and
these interviews and these television
shows and all these campaigns like
i'm just a young girl trying to figure
it out so if i do make a mistake i i try
to learn
from it and accept it and move on and
try to be better
you also called zendaya your big sis and
she plays your big sis on the show
has she ever imparted anything on you to
help
of course we've had conversations about
being in the business or just like
being a young person of being a young
woman um and i know that i can lean on
her for any type of advice that i need
but just being able to like
see her move through the world and and
see
that she is an
amazing human and and she really is
herself and and
even though she hasn't said storm just
be yourself i feel like just watching
her from shake it up to now
she just moves throughout the world with
so much grace and so much love and
kindness
so i always try to try to think about
her when i'm feeling down or feeling
like oh my god why am i in this place at
this time
i know that she would be like girl you
belong here i also want to quickly ask
you about suicide
squad to the suicide squad
it is say about your character i
think you play idris elba's daughter
right i don't know
i don't know i don't know who i play her
name is tyla that's what i can give you
but i actually i i saw a little bit of
it in adr
and it looks incredible so
that's all i can say i don't know what
else i can say i don't want to get in
trouble
but i'm super excited to be a part of it
what was it like
i know you can't confirm who your
character is but what was it like
i mean work with idris elba
he's incredible he is the nicest
person uh to work with but yet
so focused and it's so crazy how he
could
he could like go in and out so he would
be his character and
and his character is like serious and
then
when when um they would call cut he
would just like go back into
conversation and
laugh and talk and i'm like this guy is
incredible so he definitely kept me on
my toes
uh but we had a great time what will
surprise us
about your character and also this
sequel
as a whole oh
man it's a fun one it's different than
the first one but i feel like
it is incredible um and
and oh i just don't want to get in
trouble i'm trying to
select my words wisely it's a fun one
it's different from the first one but i
i think it's going to take people on a
ride
and there are lots of twisted turns and
surprises um
and as far as my character goes i mean
she's a little spicy
so you guys can expect a little bit of
spiciness from her
how how was it for you to play spicy
oh i mean i feel like it's something
that i could tap into like
she seems like a little sassy and she
has a little bit of swag
so i feel like she she kind of related
to me a little bit
does she have powers or anything or you
can't tell us i did
i don't know i totally forgot
you're good at your job